so um how how long obviously you're
going to get off tour soon about halfway
through how uh how soon are you going to
go back in and make make the next album
I'm already I'm already I'm already
working on it I've yeah I'm already
working on it I'm already working on I'm
working a lot of music right now was it
when's it early next year yeah yeah I
want to get that out first quarter so
you're not going to make everybody wait
half a decade Kevin I'm not playing with
him I'm not playing with
I was going to say like uh for you like
cuz you know a span of 5 years people
come and go right like music changes
yeah Tik Tok probably wasn't popping
like that in 2018 2019 it really wasn't
it just started actually yeah so it's
like the whole music industry kind of
changes for you like uh you know how do
you like kind of still make people give
a [__] uh cuz once you go away so long
man fans move on they find new people
like but obviously you're still doing
your thing you're the tour is going
crazy but like to me it's like hard to
like be gone for 5 years per se I mean
you were dropping some [__] but like and
like still make people care like yeah I
mean it was I was hard cuz I I was even
trying to figure it out and I feel like
it's just me being naturally honest and
myself yeah I can't do no gimmicky
[__] and feel like that's kind of
you know what I'm saying I'm just not
that person or that artist never been so
I'm just honest and that has been it's
been door opening it's been eye opening
it's been you know what I'm saying cuz
they now get to I'm letting him in I've
been so reserved I'm so closed off yeah
so I feel like cuz when I was telling
you about you know the industry and
everything I feel like it just made me
just go into my own little bubble you
know so I didn't let my even my fans in
that bubble so now that I'm letting them
in I feel like that's what I feel like
that's the only thing that they've been
missing really from me besides me
obviously dropping music right so that
connection just rebuilding that
connection you know what's what was
there anything that happened that made
you kind of like uh resent the music
industry at all um yeah the lack there I
feel like there so it was so fake I
realized man I learned how fake it
really was dog and the lack of love the
lack of you know like that's why like
you know when I like when I lose certain
people in this industry that was that
showed me genuine love like that hits
because it's like [__] like I don't
really talk to a lot of people out here
yeah people are very strange they're
very finicky in the music industry yeah
I've noticed that's what I learned they
be swinging on your dick and then like 9
months later they're they're they're
like wait what you want to answer your
call you again yeah it's crazy I didn't
there just so much clout chasing
especially at that time you know that's
when clout was so huge a lot of clout
chasing was going on and I'm just like y
I'm not into this clout [__] like I'm
just a are are you staying in La no no
I'm still back I'm still in home in
Toronto I was living in LA right before
Co and then Co I said you know what I
got free healthcare my family is there
let me just go and take advantage of
how's the free healthare work you just
uh you just go in yeah you got to get a
health card once you get the health card
then yeah free healthcare so like
certain things you got to pay for but
but like what what what's free
everything but I mean going to see the
doctor is free um let's say you got to
get get uh you blow out your ACL playing
football yeah I I don't I mean I know
everything's everything yeah I'm pretty
sure it's free yeah everything's free
surgery should be free F crazy yeah I
mean but taxes is crazy right right
taxes is where I feel like how much you
pay in taxes what it I remember SCH
0.13% is it the same yeah 0 point yeah
is it half oh that's a sales tax oh my
yeah no but like your income tax like a
lot is is it half is it more than La no
no no no no no no no no no no la [__]
no it's not like that no no no it's not
like that it's a lot but it's so you
don't pay as much man La taxes is
different bro it's [__] crazy La we
don't free healthare we got to dodge
[__] Fentanyl smok and homeless
people [__] on the streets it's crazy La
is a wild [__] place I feel it for La
man everybody's getting robbed out here
and [__] it's crazy it's crazy man Jesus
kind of everywhere right now everyone
should move to Canada and listen there
you can getting robbed too in Canada
don't get it twisted right but but you
know can you defend yourself in Canada
no oh you can't have a gun out there
right no no well how do you feel about
the Trudeau guy a lot of people don't
seem to like
him oh man everybody has mixed emotion
do you like them I mean I I like
everybody you know what I'm saying but
it's also it's politics it's politics I
don't know much about him I just know
that a lot of people I know think he's
[__] nobody everybody has there's
people like him there's people who don't
like him you know it's almost like you
know when I feel like when Trump was in
office there was people who like them
there people who don't like him right
well Trump is a maniac psychopath but
also politics boy politics yeah our
president now is a zombie so it's like
pick your poison right the orange
psychopath or you want the the half dead
you know it did you see Dwayne Johnson
they wanted him somebody wanted him to
run for office or some [__] I'd vote for
The Rock right now yeah it was crazy
yeah I mean I would too yeah for sure
yeah [__] yeah I'm not I'm not American
but I was I love are you are you a
wrestling fan yeah man what WWE was my
[__] smack know some of the greatest
wrestlers ever come from
Canada and Edmonton you know I didn't
know that growing up though I'm just all
the I met I met I met uh har yeah yeah I
met his son we I was with his son just
but uh the last one of the souls in
Calgary or when I can't remember it was
Calgary Ed yeah they're from Calgary
yeah yeah yeah yeah it was very dope
good people man good where Chris benois
was from I know he was called him the
Canadian crippler he's can I think he
was from I can't remember man the
Canadian murderer that sad story dog
yeah super sad sad story sad story man I
just kill whole family I was young I
didn't know about that story I just
watched that story recently and I
learned about it it was very steroids
story man crazy man yeah very sad sad
that's dope I need to go to Canada and
just get some free healthare could I go
out there for like two months if I need
some major [__] done get the health no
nah you got to you got to you got to get
some pregnant dog oh so you got to you
got to be a citizen so yeah you got to
be a assistant yeah figure that out go
up to Vancouver smoke some weed with
Nardo get some
surgery that's where he's from right
nard War yeah yeah yeah have you ever
met n
totally other side of the country I mean
yeah but I love Vancouver but I never
met him yet nor holl at me man what's
going on smells crazy that's the crazy
thing to say I've met him like five
times every time that's
outrageous how you just saying that
about me N I don't know I don't I've
literally met him four or five times
sweetest guy yeah he's got the worst Bo
I've ever smell him did you tell him
like he's a r I told him I said you're
ripe aren't
you it's a ripe ass [__] dude right
there man I don't think he has time to
shower he's too busy doing research you
know he's Savage my boy you you nard
War's doing research the whole time you
don't have time to shower that's crazy D
that motherfucker's too busy like on the
dark web trying to find out stuff about
people oh man hey he said hey you got n
interview soon yeah I do man I'm give
you some tips I got to I need to come
with my skin skincare routine for some
for these [__] man I need to need to
get it going get it popping
uh how much uh are you finished with
this new album uh 20% 30% half I would
say about half a little bit more than
that you working on the road or no yeah
I'm working on the road yeah yeah yeah
always I love working on the road so
insiration is there anybody who you have
who have come out in the last like five
or six years that you would consider
like a newer artist that you would love
to work with that you're just a fan of
um first person that came to mind beia
so fire man yeah be when I when she
started popping I was taking her taking
in her music a lot she's so [__] fire
she's super fire and she's like the
coolest chick ever yeah never met her
yet yeah but yeah she's mad cool man
she's from Boston yeah oh sorry East
Side well I mean yeah you know have you
been to Boston yeah I love Boston
Boston's A vibe I love Boston they got
good food there yeah just a lot of like
uh you know Dusty white women there I
actually I don't know about that I've
ran into a lot of Latinos like yeah
especially there's a lot of Puerto Rican
chicks in Lawrence Lawrence
Massachusetts Lawrence which is right
outside very specific I used to DJ there
aot it's either bad bad Latin women or
chicks that sound like Ted the the teddy
bear movie you are something else
dog every every white chick in Boston
sounds like they've [__] smoked for
30 years we talking about with that
accent [__] Tom
Brady [__] Tom I want to hear I've
never heard of Boston accent
let's get in the Uber baby I would love
to hear a boss I've never heard of you
oh you will one day you have a groupy
and then as soon as she opens her mouth
she'll become unattractive to you be
like oh [__] cuz you be like God damn
have you ever have you ever hit uh with
that accent
no no not at all couldn't do it nope
nope nope no good good good I feel that
lots of k k Verdian women over there
though lots of what Cape Verdian women
from cap oh really yeah damn really
random super fire random um all right so
look the tour is going down right now um
people uh how many dates left uh um
about what five five or so all right so
go get some tickets uh the album came
out what in July June uh August August
or
July yeah July supp the album new music
right at the end of July you're not
going to make everybody wait for new
music like uh last time no no I I'm
working on it right now yeah L and I got
a EP yeah I got a EP and album so I'm
trust me I'm doubling it up when's the
EP dropping first uh I might yeah I'm
going to drop the EP first year um if
not this year then definitely beginning
of next year all right you got a lot of
music coming yeah man lots of music so
they're not going to miss Roy Woods man
Roy Woods appreciate you pulling up
brother thank you for having yes sir
[__] the Steelers hey [__] you
man [__]
you most polite [__] you ever such a
Canadian [__] you